歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是艾倫
台股超級猛
很猛耶
全世界最強
這樣子開一平盤
然後漲八百點
一盤中就是這樣
一路拉一路拉一路拉
因為今天韓股跟日股沒有表現
昨晚美股廢伴也沒什麼表現
其實對啊
台式一夜盤也沒表現
因為美股還是籠罩在
9月的升息機率大幅飆升的狀況
沒錯
但我們有不一樣的事情
昨天晚上我們就有看到
所謂的
徽達跟聯發科的結盟
沒錯
恭喜我們發科也加入AI央行的行列
發科加入了徽達央行
沒錯
因為徽達去買了發科的殼賺
在認購35億美元
九成
好 那加入到底好不好呢
你的感想是什麼
好啊
我說你覺得今天
台股會長成這樣會意外嗎
我覺得蠻意外的
因為我還是會看一下
期貨的表現
期貨其實沒什麼表現
也沒有弱
但這樣子開盤
就一路拉到收盤
其實我有點嚇到
就怎麼 這到底在拉什麼
你知道今天講的
就是我內心的澎湃嗎
就是昨天晚上
我看到那個新聞的時候
我就覺得
我對台灣半導體的發展
的景仰如滔滔江水
好 對 湮綿不絕
相信國家隊
真的有這樣的感覺
很驕傲耶
怎麼講呢
不是只因為發歌
不是只因為揮答
是因為發歌現在人人搶耶
是啊
谷歌也要 對不對
然後揮答也要
想當初
想當初怎麼樣
他在那邊手機對不對
對
想當初其實是在一個
大家覺得不會成長的市場
是的
可是順利切進AI
而且有十年的藍圖
把它一起畫出來了
沒錯
這個跟這個
2010年那個時候的
聯發科也是一樣
是
就山寨基出生
對
然後突然就耀生起來
是不是
對 然後十幾年後
過去之後
又下一個階段
對
所以他們其實很會把握時機
嗯
好 很棒
然後再來的話
我們台積電
在最近有一系列的論壇
還包括半導體站
都有提到
矽光子
市占率跟渗透率会大幅飙升
没错
所以其实矽光
还有今天这个IP股
我们其实都还蛮强势的
当然台积舰今天也不错
不过今天引领大盘的
是我们一次所的发哥
等一下会看一下
那我们来看一下
其实我们刚刚讲的很澎湃
台湾股市很强
但其实美国股市
是有一个阴霾在的
所以我们也要稍微压抑一下
棒打出头鸟
没错
我们来看一下
华许在上礼拜五的
这个Jackson Hall講出來的話呢就還是如預期的偏音派一點點因為他認為通膨啊就很明确我的目标就是2%但现在就是3%多所以他还是想要
偏音一点的讲法啦
那目前来说讲完之后呢
整个9月原本是三成左右的几率呢
升息直接拉到了66%
真的很高耶
而且剩没几天耶
剩两周耶
9月16嘛
对啊 所以剩两周的时间
会不会就真的跟你
迅雷不禁耳的升出来
其實這兩週還有一些轉圜的餘地
像是要公布的非農
下個禮拜的CPI
只要數字好看一點點
這個機率還是有機會降下來的
所以我覺得我目前還是比較站在
它不太可能升息的角度
因為美債殖利率
不管是10年級還是30年級
就已經都漲翻天了
那你這個錢都是誰要去出
美國政府要出
美國財政赤字
因為利息要付很多
所以現在滑雪其實有點尷尬
因為通膨壓不下來
但如果我繼續升息的話
那美国赤字只会更严重
所以他是左右为难
左右夹击
现在就是为难的
川普也很为难
怎么有派任的人
都没在听我的
真的
但是他感觉
好像川普比较不骂他
对不对
上一个
骂蛮凶的
好 再来另外一个就是
今天早上又传出来
美意又开战了
然后刚刚我们录影的
稍早大概一两个小时前
其实这个游船
有两颗飞弹射过去
对 所以台子夜盘
才又突然跌下
那這件事情
可能在近期內
還是會持續影響股市
大家還是要注意一下
不管是原油的價格
還是因為原油推升的
美債值率的價格
美債值率的趴數
大家要稍微注意一下
可能在美國股市上
這些都會是短線的陰霾
大家稍微注意一下
好 那我們來繼續看下來
就是這個發哥的部分
回答呢 投資35億美金
那原本是預計發行
39億的ECB
結果回答呢
就直接就九成去了
包走了
为我而发这种感觉
没错没错
35亿OK买买买
类似这种感觉
那当然也非常好
带动了今天
联发科直接一自所
就在这里一根
所以就看一看就觉得
结束了
看期望8点45分
而且就跟他的可转载的
转换价差不多了
是的
所以目前来说
发科形态上
我觉得还没有
还没有打出N字形
还没有
当然今天一自所
还是没什么
已經沒什麼好挑剔的
然後也帶動一些IP股
今天表現不錯
創意是自己原本就很強了可能有一些漲多的一個回落創高壓回是的那其實還有一檔聯發科有相关的那就是雍智科雍智科技探针系列的对 就是帮联发科做的
那今天也是一字所
所以后面如果要看一下
有没有动能延续性
大家再自己斟酌一下
好 这个是发科的部分
非常不错
那今天发科全值也在很重
所以涨停之后
其实开盘就不太弱了
那我觉得是好事
因为我们台湾股市指数如果好
那大家的信心就会比较足够一点
再来另外一个就是
整个西光子在从8月以来的
延续性都还不错
那持续进入9月了
我觉得应该还有一些表现的机会
对 那这个半导体展呢
台积电有来做加持
相关的呢
会说是今年还会再年增50%
是
然后明年会再继续的
向上去做推升
所以目前看起来都还是
一个偏乐观的状态
我们台湾西光子一直很幸福的
就是台积电其实蛮加持这个族群的
对的 因为它可能做COOC
也是很需要做這種東西
好 那有一些相關的
AI半導體的先進封裝
然後跟細光子的CPU高速傳輸
還有量子技術 晶圓製造
還有化合物半導體
跟實體AI的中端應用
基本上還是圍繞在整個AI發展
從能源到實體應用的狀態
去做商機的一些部分
好 現在反而什麼事情
都是規模越來越大
沒錯
晶圓製造
他們現在諧音梗用得很兇
科技也淪落了
也喜欢血腥梗
好那细光子有相关的
随着铜线传输进入物理极限
所以细光子是必须要发展的技术
那再来台积电
预约光还有流明光学
都有登台大秀相关的技术
另外CPU技术下半年会正式量产
2027年会渗透率超过了五成
所以目前看起来应该都是一个
火热发展的状态
虽然我们还在定义叫做渗透率突破五成
是什么意思
但是總之台積電這樣講了嘛
對
所以已經有很多在創新高的路上了
沒有錯
那我們等一下下半場
要不要跟大家講一下
哪一些是看低做高
好 今天大
看高做低啦 說錯了
看低做高也沒錯
也是動能派的
OK OK OK
好 我們來看一下大牌
大牌呢
我們在前一陣子跟大家說
這邊這一根紅K
突破了一個小翔形
那接下來要挑戰的呢
就是這個高點
那這個高點呢
在今天是明確的去站上了
其實昨天台湾股市就很強
昨天我們是反映了
週五的滑雪利空
所以其實跌了七八百點
那不過呢我們在昨天拉了一個七百點的下影線然後呢還沒有跌破任何的均線五日均跟十日均碰到再收盤價都有站上所以就非常的強勢的意思
然後在今天總算做了一個突破
這個突破我覺得就是一個N字形的確立
這個心高高前高有沒有
這裡心低高前低
所以目前來說我覺得即便出現回落
即便出現漲多震盪
在現在的形態來講的話
我個人都認為都是回落要記得
找買電
對對要上車
那昨天的量比較大
因為昨天有MSEI激度調整
所以今天就直接做突破
那我覺得應該就是更好的意思
好那另外呢
給大家幾個關鍵均線
第一個就是月線
你看這邊碰月線拉新高
對
所以這一大段呢
觀察的重點可以拉在月線的部分
好就是要守在月線上
沒錯
那再來這一小段呢
目前看起來還沒走完
那有回落的時候
給大家一個比較更具體的位置
就是十日均线
十日均线呢
就会代表这一段的行情的
关键均线
那这一大段的呢
是月线
所以一个是小的格局
一个是大一点的格局
对 那只要这两个状态都还在
基本上这行情啊
有回落都不要太怕
相对的如果有回落跌破
那就记得可能涨多
要进入一个高涨争利了
那目前没有
所以目前还是偏向乐观去看待
再来贵买
贵买呢
finally
我们这边是七月中跌破
是
睽違了一个半月
我们终于站回季线了
對 因為貴買漲的就顯然沒有加權那麼健康樣
對 但是這兩天
或者說這一段時間的走勢
其實貴買沒有輸
因為CPU或者是說一些碳增系列的
群值都蠻重的 貴買部分
那今天環球晶也總算有點回神
對啊 因為環球晶占貴買很大群重
是的 所以今天的這個貴買表現
其實是不錯的 有漲到2.26%
然後也是有一個季線的突破了
可是高點差一點點
盤中最高點有突破
但它還沒有形成一個N字形
這比較可惜一點
但至少站回季線
所以我覺得貴買指數
目前的表現
也值得後面的行情的期待
我覺得大中小股
應該大家都可以好好關注一下
而且成交量我們都陸續回穩了
這一段時間成交量都回來了
回到兆了
沒錯 所以我覺得量能出來了
然後形態也出來了
那我覺得就是好好去關注
有沒有機會有一些動能的股票了
好 那我們接下來看一下新興
好 因為星星不管
大家會從各個方面來講
不過我覺得單純從形態來看
是不是已經止跌了
我覺得今天這一根超級
确实在短线上是值得去做一个
短线抄底的动作
因为你停车点很好抓
我们说高档爆量的时候
要记得跑嘛 对不对
那低档爆量的时候呢
可以接看看 为什么
因为今天最低点911嘛
可是我好怕它无量跌停的那种感觉
我觉得这样比较难耶
难喔 对 这样很难在底部
无量跌停了
因为已经一堆人冲进去跟你
低点911
对啊 没错 我有记的
那收盤价971嘛
所以你今天如果尾盘做进场
提損点就是今天低点跌破
那表示什么 换手失败嘛
这个这么大量一定大幅度换手
换手失败 听起来好可怕
9万多耶
可是你的停损就60块啊
但是如果你换回来 涨回去
那你至少这边跌停
这一根是会赚回来的
对 那你要不要看要不要
这种子可能5-6%的空间
去换个10%以上的涨幅
其实我觉得单就强短这个角度来讲
我觉得今天是值得试试看的
但是以他们目前产业的角度来讲
其实我觉得可能要再听看听一下
对 因为他们这次
其实大家应该都知道
我们就不赘述了
他就是讲的是
他ABF是最占钱的
但是被减掉的是PCB的部分
那PCB的部分占整个新兴的营收
其实不到三成
而且毛利率最好的ABF
其实是完全不受影响的
对 那以战略这个角度来讲
这种事件其实照常来讲
长线应该合理回去股价是要回去的
但重点是这个减掉
才刚开始两三天
那又还没有整个减掉完毕
所以后面会不会有更重要的状态
这个我们也不知道
那如果有
这个可能就要继续走回落
那相对的如果结束了
那我觉得行情就结束
那时候再来买
其实也不会太迟
所以我觉得以站在事件性的角度来讲
我会等事件确立的
再来看要不要进场
好 而且也不要
昨天就怕自己卖不掉
今天觉得千万不要卖
好像很厉害了
就是一天
不同的情绪
情绪都不太一样
而不是有任何的纪律
可能也是要避免的
是的
所以欣欣
大家如果跟短线
跟产业角度来讲
想法是完全不一样的
大家来自己参考了
好 既然你有注意到
关键数字
你知道八月份
涨了几点吗
是一个关键数字
八月份你说大盘吗
对啊
大盘涨几点
大盘涨了3008
是谁的代号呢
是大力光的
是大力光
所以在下一段节目里面
我们就要跟大家分享
到底这一次
矽光子在台积电的加持还有大力光是领头羊联亚也创新高的情况下谁有标股基因等一下一档一档帮您数
好 我们来看一下近期的大标兵
3008大力光
没错 很厉害啊
我们来看一下
其实大力光之前他有法说
他法说说 他们自己有说
他们9月的时候一开始很不错
股价8月就先快一倍
其实他们目前营收都略显平淡
可是不知道什么股价
已经飙到快8000了
没错
其实因为开两次法说了
他第一次法说是开成法会
因为很老实
说2028才会有CPU
没错
然后6月就自己出来讲说
9月我们可以好好关注一下
我们的表现
那8月的时候就已经先拉了
接近9成的一个涨幅
大力光确实
营收可能还没出来
但是它的动作频频
这很猛
你就这样一直买
要是你看到一家保守的公司
爸爸一直在买地
对啊
对不对
好有钱
你看六月
这个行动力会让你印象很深
对啊
六月 七月买两个
然后八月再买两个
总共买了六十一点五亿
所以这个应该是近年
应该非常大的一个
劣地的一个状态了
要是我看到你连买五栋房子
我也知道你发了
赚大钱了
对啊
是不是好明白
是的 那目前來說
他們自己有去提到
整個相關的產品
第三季底會建置完成
最快是明年年中會準備就緒
但是也有反而認為
這個平凡的購地
是不是想要大舉去做一些狀態
或者說他們其實產業整個的流暢
是非常那個什麼
進度是非常順暢的
所以這股價這一波
就搭著CPU的熱潮一起去墊高
當然其實也不只大力光橋
但確實CPU其中一個指標股
是看大力光没有错
那另外一个可能就是
看联亚跟全新
所以目前来说
整个CPU大割级
或者说这一波先拉起来
只要形态上没有转弱的趋势
可以整理 但不要有转弱
其实我觉得低位阶
就有机会做轮动补障了
是
我们就先把领头羊
神主牌放在那
然后来看谁有标股基因
这个创高的有联亚
一口气就回到3000多块
然后联均也创新高了
光环处置中还是持续创新高
對 那全新今年也漲停板
所以我覺得
這一些都是創新高的
那目前呢有在漲 但還沒創新高的就會是這一些好 補漲型的是的 那当然其实顶元也是创新高因为最近有一些新题材
也是可能前一阵子
没有列在CPU里面
那近期有跟着一起去做
一个强势表现
就像提到顶元
大力光其实都是
今年才有CPU利多的
这些都是两年前就在CPU的
好 所谓的第一代CPU
没错 那第一代呢
这一次的走势
就稍微比较落后新的一代
但我覺得型態都打出來了
所以後面CPU就那幾支
只要這個題材一直在
我覺得落後補長是有機會的
那目前來說整個的營收
還是有一些是EPS是負的
就是台積電的這個上全
然後光環
光環應該後續會非常不錯
因為有一個轉機的狀態
好 那我們來看一下裡面幾位
首先第一個就是上全了
我覺得它真的有點傷腦筋
因為你看到林亞在衝
那林亞的營收真的是開得非常的
對啊 成長率高
可是它到底要什麼時候才要成長
真的就是
難道真的是繼續靠台積列嗎
不是總是要開始量產
或是說合作進度
應該要有一定的推進吧
但它確實有一下子好了
但馬上又回到溫溫的狀態
那不過沒關係
我們就來看一下型態
從型態來看好了
是的 型態這邊大量
大量這地方
然後這裡也挑戰一次
沒有過
那到了前一陣子
最近終於過了
去做突破
那突破之后呢
股价就开始去做一个延伸
去垫高了
所以这边的底部
基本上是确立的
对 这个底部是确立的
至少打好一个底了
没错 那打好底之后呢
成交量也可以陆续看到
都呈现了一个开始量增
然后价格有去做上扬的状态
所以目前来说
我们刚刚提到了嘛
一些什么联军啊
还有这个联雅
其实都已经突破
他的自己的高点了
但上全距离他的高点呢
其实还有一些空间
所以这边有机会
做一个落后补涨的效应
我会觉得在回落过程中
延续趋势都还在的话
要记得去做一个介入的状态
对 毕竟是最早就传出
是台移电首批成任的伙伴
对 两年前的时候
上全还在双位数
现在一度到900块
快四位数呢
而且那时候讲还有人说
有吗 台移电有成任吗
可是后来是真的有讲
是的 是的
所以目前来说
上全底部有一个转好的形态
我覺得再回落的過程
大家記得可以去沿著軍線去做操作
因為人家體不是確立的
加油喔 你已經先搶得頭籌了沒錯 再來看到就是穩帽然後穩前就人家說買穩帽就穩套去年啦 去年那個時候那個嘛
就是養殖場事件
對 那目前都已經結束了
所以穩帽在今年的時候
其實那一段其實漲幅
它是完全領先全新的
前面有到600多
沒錯 沒錯
那不過穩帽這一次反彈
或者說這一波下跌的狀態
其實都遜於全新
因为全新今天已经
前两天就创新高了
历史新高了
那稳貌呢
股价还走到整个下跌的一个
五成到六成之间的距离
对 所以我觉得它还有补涨空间
那一样嘛 都零化银题材
然后这边形态
也刚做了一个底部的确立
这里也是一个很明确的N字形
那量价也都是开始拉出来
所以这个才刚跟季线去做一个突破
甚至拉开一些小乖离而已
我觉得这个位阶来讲
当然啦这个都是已经涨上来的形态
可是我们要比较的是
那一些创高的
那一些创高只要不要重跌
它可以在高档不创高
高档震荡等均线跟上
那这一些呢开始形态打出来的
距离前高都还有点空间的
我觉得都值得注意一下
因为大家一定会在想
哇CPU这个题材还是很热
那有哪一些我可以
从地位接再买上来
他们可能还是需要
有价差才愿意进场
那这一些就可以是一些
大家好好去注意的一些表弟
而且他們都是之前大家很關注的
所以小朋友應該都多多少少
對他們有興趣過
沒錯 這邊都受傷過
我必須說
對 那時候有興趣都是受傷
這個受傷很重
但是這邊跟他講還不一樣
形態不一樣
對 形態不一樣
量價也出來了
好 再來另外一個就是華星光
華星光是有獎狀的
因為在7月28號有率先獎他
他也是有業績的公司
是的
而且從7月28號到現在
大概一个月就涨了40%
对 所以它其实这一波的时候
是率先去垫高的
但目前来说它的走势相对
可能前高比较远
因为它这一波跌的也是蛮重的
对 然后华星光上礼拜五才刚开法说
那讲的我觉得应该是非常的不错
所以目前来说
股价上面临了一个短线
就是进储置的状态
它好像还是很容易进储置
对 这边也进储置
这边也进储置
明明是有获利的公司
是的 可是从8月以来
其实大家可以去注意
有一些像热门题材的
然后它进处置的时候
准备要放出来的时候
〔此段辨識失敗，約 20:00 起〕